would you say that when you get into
those uh mind states where you're very
like you start thinking about [ __ ] like
that do you look to your kids as like an
as the number one way to push through a
small that's my number one Outlet yeah
other than like the studio and you know
what I'm saying just having fun with the
people I love my family you know what
I'm saying
um my girl and [ __ ] like that like
that's the only piece that I really have
you feel me when it's
Smiles happiness I don't like Argo I
don't like confrontation because
I can't you know balance my emotions I
have to keep my emotions bottled in one
place so I don't like confrontation I
don't like to
especially with people that I care about
because I don't want to of course
release that angle yeah I'm saying so my
only like pure form or like pieces being
with my kids at all bro like period
that's the only time I could think about
nothing in the world or Nothing Else
Matters I can't be angry around my kids
all they want to do is play and smash
right right right right right right yeah
and you have you have a lot like you're
living for them now you know what I'm
saying not just yourself